welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go with
each video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 10 and we're going to learn how you
can build your confidence we all want to
be able to change the way we feel that's
what I spend my life showing people how
to deal on what most people know is the
emotion is created by motion the way you
move determines the way you feel you
have 80 different muscles in your face
80 for most people this is the largest
area of unemployment in the country they
use their mate the face the same way
they feel the same emotions over and
over and over again so what I'm saying
is I have a just deal with myself called
priming every day I say look you've got
to have 10 minutes for yourself you
don't 10 minutes to yourself you don't
have a life and I'm not gonna hope I
feel good I don't got back six countries
in 12 days I was in India two days ago
Wow I woke up here like feeling like
somebody ran me over they do this
process it's ten minutes it put some
music on I do this massive change in my
breathing so it radically changes the
way I feel and then I do this three step
process first I do three minutes of
gratitude or I think of three things I'm
really grateful for and I associate I
don't think of it over that I feel it
and the reason is when you're grateful
you can't be worried it can't be fearful
when you're grateful you can't be angry
and anger and fear what screw people up
most in their relationships and their
life in their business so I wire myself
I'm saying to you that most people want
to be happy but their habit is to be
worried or pissed off or frustrated or
stress and so they're they've got a high
way to stress and they got a dirt road
to happiness
so I wire myself I've got a highway to
gratitude which changes all your
emotions and then I do three-minute
process of kind of a prayer for my
family and friends and then I do a
three-minute process of the top three
things I want to accomplish I see it as
done I feel I'm done in 10 minutes so
sometimes I go 20 but my deal is 10 so
there's no excuse not to do it how do I
get more conference it starts with
yourself man you got to start diving
into those things that you are afraid of
you don't gain confidence by going to
the spot that makes you feel good
it could be a false reality in the
second life gives you that challenge all
you want to do is go back to what makes
you confidence or what gave you
confidence is that happy spot no what
gives you confidence what gave me
confidence was spending years at a
kitchen table trying to learn how to
read and write all my own realizing I
can't learn the way you learn I can't
but I can't learn but gives you
confidence not being afraid it's
overcoming the fear Isis stutter
severely bad so right now I don't know
how many people are gonna watch this
know what gives me confidence is knowing
I'm no longer care you know if I say or
start stuttering to you yeah that's what
gives me compass its facing these things
overcoming them if they be not
overcoming them everyday but facing them
and facing the face and pretty like
there's no one man this is where it's at
hmm it's not in that comfort zone it's
in the discomfort zone is where my
confidence is getting built mm-hmm
that's where it's getting built but
people want to they want to ease your
answer yeah there has to be an easier
way it's not I'm sorry I searched for it
my entire life when I'm with cooler or
popular guys I feel inferior and
worthless which affects me and weirdly I
try so hard to impress them and be like
them like a chameleon I try to avoid
them but I feel left out whatever I do I
feel sad or useless what can I do in
order to overcome this you don't have to
hang out with people you don't like
there's a pro life tip for everybody you
don't have to one of the things that is
a massive indication that you're hanging
out with the wrong group of people is
that you don't feel comfortable being
yourself
the second you try to be somebody else
or you feel like a chameleon just to fit
in you are trying to fit in with the
wrong group relationships only work when
you can be the real you people thrive on
energy that's what drives connection
you're with people that make you wither
and hide and feel insecure you are with
the wrong people if it's hard to be
around people you're with the wrong
group of people when relations
chips work they work because they click
and the reason why they click is because
you can be the real you they don't make
you feel inferior you're making yourself
feel inferior by hanging out with people
and pretending you're not yourself so
every time you're hanging out with a
group of people and you act like a
chameleon you're actually invalidating
yourself because your own actions are
telling you you're not good enough to
just be yourself around these people so
the only way to deal with this is either
show up with that group of people and be
your full self and every time you think
something inferior just knock that
thought out of your mind say what you
really believe be interested in what
you're really interested in or the
easier route honestly drop the popular
kids and find your people you need to
find your people and your people are the
kind of people that the second you hang
out with them you don't feel like less
of yourself you feel like more of
yourself you don't feel like you got to
hide or be somebody else you feel like
you want to express yourself and show up
and be more of yourself that's the
indication that you have found your
people study the alchemy now here's what
I mean by that what happens to most
people in life especially the victims is
they reach a part of their life you know
a difficult time and they call it
failure I mean even just labeling a
setback as a failure
trigger something into your mindset to
release cortisol the fear hormone which
blocks your best performance and so
you'll want to see yourself and you want
to study the alchemy which is where
other people are seeing a failure or
setback or even a little problem you
want to look for the gold you want to
train your brain so you have a dominant
belief it just becomes automatic because
you've practiced it so much where when
someone says there's a problem or
there's a wall or there's a failure you
literally see the alchemy to turn the
lead into gold maybe you're going
through a divorce maybe you're going
through an illness a lot of people who
watch this podcasts are going through
difficulties or outright tragedies but
you want to practice seeing the setback
or the dark time as few
fool to leverage your growth and so on
this first point about study the alchemy
no matter what you're going through in
your life whether it's a large
difficulty or a small setback you want
to ask yourself how can I use what I'm
going through as fuel for my growth you
want to ask yourself what is the
gorgeous opportunity hidden inside this
so-called problem I mean and if you look
at the mass of humanity they really
train their brains to focus on problems
right the hit a wall and they just
because of their belief system they
don't know it because most people are
not really that aware of their belief
systems so they blame it on the world
they blame it on the supplier they blame
it on the teammate they blame it on
their husband or wife they blame it on
their childhood versus understanding our
daily performance reflects our deepest
beliefs and so if you are experiencing
some kind of setback whether its large
or tiny you want to train your brain to
see the treasure within the LED and one
of the greatest hang-ups that people
have is the belief in themselves they
they suffer from something called
self-doubt many years ago I read
something it was by um Ralph Waldo
Emerson it was this essay on
self-reliance that's what we want to do
we want to rely on self and in that he
said there would come a time in every
person's education when they realized
that envy is ignorance and imitation is
suicide so many people look at someone
that's doing very well possibly in the
same field they're in and envy them do
you know what that's saying that's
saying I don't know that I have the same
mental faculties you've got I'm drawing
on the same potential that you're
drawing on there is only one mind I
don't know that so I'm gonna in view
thinking you can do something I'm not
able to do the truth is if you can do it
I can do it envy is ignorance it's not
knowing that and he said imitation is
suicide
do you know that nothing in this
universe would move in
precise order it moves in your absence
that's true
everything in the universe is essential
you take any part away from anything
it's not complete and everything in the
universe moves in a very precise way so
do you see we shouldn't even want to be
like anybody else because we are unique
we are truly unique there's something
like about us said you'll never find in
another person we're unique
and we've got the godlike ability to
think now what is self-doubt self-doubt
is the opposite of self-confidence
confidence comes from understanding like
I would imagine you're confident you can
drive your car in fact you're so
confident that you'll be talking to
somebody on the phone you'll get in the
car you'll start the car you'll Drive
and you'll drive maybe four or five
blocks not even be unaware of what
you've done it's all done automatic your
concentration is on the conversation
you're on now when you first got in a
car you couldn't do that the car was
probably jumping all over the place and
you thought you'd never learned how to
drive it but you learned how to drive it
now you're quite confident you're
confident that you can get dressed when
you get up in the morning when you're a
little boy or a little girl you couldn't
do that you had to be taught to do it
well you know self confidence comes like
all confidence that comes with knowledge
and the more you study you the more you
understand who you are the more
confident you'll become in your ability
to do whatever it is you're doing and
you'll know that if you like confidence
in an area it's because you liked
information in that area never doubt
yourself and when you do understand that
the cause of that doubt is not lying
within you it's in wrong thinking it's
you not understanding who you are study
yourself self study will develop self
confidence and self confidence
eliminates self doubt
where does self confidence come from
right which is important because there's
no relationship between that and eroding
yourself confidence in other words self
confidence is really self trust so the
first thing is the people I know that
are really happy are very self aware in
fact the best entrepreneurs I know are
very self-aware they're aware of their
shortcomings
they want to improve them they want to
get to the next version of themselves
all the time and so for me
self-confidence comes because I didn't
have it and I think anytime you meet
somebody like yourself or myself who
might now appear self-confident it's
because I really had to find tools and
resources because I was so insecure and
shy and introverted so I had to find
techniques and resources to build that
up in me and for me it's very simple
it's the promises that I keep to myself
if I have a habit over and over again to
stack one on top of the other of keeping
promises I make to me not other people
in other words the minute you begin to
get external in your life worrying about
what other people think about you right
you've out you've lost all control you
and it never fills you up and people's
admiration people's gratitude towards
you will never fill you up it's your own
it's your own inside and so for me
self-confidence comes from keeping the
promises I make to myself and the other
part of it is being aware I'm doing it
in other words most people don't give
themselves enough credit all the time
they're very aware of these 20 percent
things and not aware of the 80 right and
that's why the dosage is so important -
you've nailed it it should be 80/20
right because people get addicted to
this I'm not good at this people don't
like this about me I don't feel good
instead of focusing on the 80 and
stacking it up wow I did eat what I said
I was going to today I did get up when I
said I was going to I made the amount of
phone calls I treated people in such a
way I promised myself it's not just
doing those things it's rewarding it's
being aware of it and stacking that up I
always grew up heavyset like and larger
than most people in my class or my
family like the younger girls in my
family my immediate family member my dad
they never really made me feel that way
like in all of my videos of when I was
younger I'm in front of the camera like
super happy my mom was like an
instructor like a fitness instructor she
had like six-pack ABS when I was going
over yeah she was super fair she would
kind of dragged me to all of our classes
but I noticed it most when I started
going to school obviously you end up
seeing people around you and the girls
around you and the type of people that
end up being liked or dislikes and you
realize that actually ends up being a
lot to do with your physical form what I
want to go to what you
said about your mom having six-pack yeah
like did that did it dawn on you at the
time like was there any envy or did it
make you feel badly or you don't you
like now it was just a happy-go-lucky
kid and it was cool that my mom had abs
no I definitely felt it like you
definitely feel it from young age and
emotionally it was more when people
would make comments about it or when you
can't fit into things or when you see
yourself in like a video with your the
rest of your family or your cousins and
you're like the chubby kid in the corner
you know you don't but the confidence
level I think only changed when I got to
school and it was there was I was
surrounded by girls who I thought were
more beautiful than me or skinnier than
me and it's so weird I always feel that
now looking back thinking that Fitness
was always related to how skinny you
were like that was my my image ever
growing up that's all I thought that to
be fit that means you have to be really
really slim and it wasn't necessarily
because of my mom but it's just what you
end up growing up looking at all over
the places women wanting to be super
slim and in my eyes that meant for me to
be fair I had to be skinny so how did
you not let that erode your self-worth
or did it you wrote yourself what I
think it definitely did because growing
up your self-worth
I feel is based on everybody around you
when your teenager is how many guys like
you or whether the guy you like likes
you back that ends up defining whether
you love yourself or whether your
friends love you you're not stable you
have no routing and so everything that
you base your love for your cell phone
ends up being external and so I
definitely had ups and downs of really
thinking I was something when somebody
likes me and then when somebody didn't
like me or my friends decided not to be
friends with me I would dislike myself
and so everything was based on external
validation for sure and how did you stop
that loop then or when do you remember
the first time you recognized it that it
was illusion yeah I felt that way for a
long time that I felt something was
missing
I knew that my love for myself could not
be based on other people there had to be
something else that I could have a
foundation of okay fine they can be ups
and downs but I never go down to a low
where I don't love myself and I
definitely think meditation was the
turning point for me and I felt that
because it was the one time in the day
I would end up spending time with myself
like you I feel that people don't do
that we spend time on everything to do
with hair and makeup and clothes and on
other people looking at other people
talking to other people but I felt like
I wasn't spending any time actually
thinking Who am I like I don't know who
I am and I feel like in a relationship
with others with yourself or whether
it's with somebody else you have to know
yourself to love yourself
we never get into relationships with
people or friendships with people
without knowing them we can't fall in
love with someone without knowing them
and so I felt like okay Who am I I
actually don't know who I am I don't
know why I like I don't know I dislike
everything that I like or dislike is
based on other people everything that I
like about myself is based on other
people's like this saying oh you got
beautiful exactly exactly and so
everything is to do with oh they like it
so that must be Who I am and so I found
meditation was the first time or just
journaling was the first time I started
writing down things about things I liked
about myself or don't like about myself
and so it created more of like a
relationship with with me I was having a
relationship with myself finally rather
than my perception of myself because of
other people god I love that there are
some people around us who just seem like
they are born with natural confidence
you know what I'm talking about
they're super smooth super confident
they always know the right thing to say
think about President Obama it just
seems like a smooth guy think of one of
his famous yes we can rally speeches not
being political here just talking about
his oratorical skills what do you notice
about how he speaks he's powerful he's
decisive he speaks slowly and almost
never stumbles or stutters his points
are clear and they're to the point he's
the epitome of confidence when it comes
to a speaker on stage so when you look
at somebody like him it's very easy to
assume that he has some innate ability
that he was born with either you have it
or you don't but the truth is confidence
is a skill
and President Obama just like all
confident people built that skill he
practiced it over a lifetime so here's a
simple example of how you can control
your confidence in less than 20 seconds
take something you routinely say like
what you did this weekend and change the
way you say I want you to channel your
inner super confident person it could be
Barack Obama
it could be Susan Sarandon it could be
whoever you want don't focus on who it
is don't even worry about what you say
instead focus on changing how you say it
sit up straight
speak slowly and imagine what you're
saying is incredibly important because
the people listening want to hear it let
me show you an example a little before
and after yeah I can't even remember I
mean I think it was pretty good it was
actually pretty crazy but I just went to
a movie and saw some friends you know
the usual I guess now let's compare the
after we had a great weekend I was with
the kids on Saturday then Michelle and I
caught a Broadway show and finished the
night at that new sake bar downtown now
what you notice notice first that I'm
intentionally using someone else to role
play this really lets us get into play
acting without worrying about our own
life our own Saturday ooh maybe I don't
have as cool the life as going to a sock
a bar don't worry about that all we're
doing here is working on our delivery
remember nobody sees inside of you they
don't see how confident you are how much
work you spent practicing all they see
is the way you answer a question or the
way you sit when you're talking to them
so when it comes to confidence
confidence can actually come from the
outside in not just from the inside out
which
what everybody tells you so instead of
waiting for it to just magically appear
where's my confidence where is it we're
actually changing our behavior something
everyone can do and we're letting the
confidence follow the external
influences the internal and once you
master this concept you can apply it to
a lot more than just how you speak and
how you sit I want you to borrow
confidence from the past
you see when we're doing something where
we have to muster up the confidence we
think of the things that could go wrong
we think of what if I don't come through
what if I don't say the right things I
need to rehearse this over and over what
if what if what if what if we change
that and instead of thinking about what
could go wrong of course we know this
start thinking about what can go right
but better yet rob confidence from the
past go look in your past at times when
you weren't sure if you go through but
you made it happen
when you thought you wanted the girl and
you got the girl or you got the guy you
got the job you got the deal you got the
money you got the sale a type of you you
you scored the touchdown you got the run
you we're good at band you you were the
star of the play rob confidence from the
past remind your body remind yourselves
remind your subconscious what it felt
like and bring it into the present time
I'm telling you you can transcend that
old confidence into your current state
and watch your changing your state of
mind change just like that I get kicked
out of college I got kicked out of
college my second year because I didn't
want to continue to run track I took my
team undefeated the first year Wow and
they went from not having won a track
meet in two years at all to going
undefeated in two in one year you could
attribute what allowed you to lead the
team to do that and one or two insights
what would it be I had unwavering
confidence did you cultivate that or was
it natural but I cultivated at home or
was it personally cultivated my dad and
my mom they they I don't know if he was
brainwashed or encouraged me conquering
anything yeah like bait bait
I wasn't opposition didn't scare me it's
never half scare me like I don't look at
how how big the mountain is if I can
climb it I go are we gonna climb it and
what do we need to climb that size
mountain you don't measure if I can do
something based on
the size of the opposition you decide we
don't do it and then decide what to do
for that particular scenario very
different strategy when you look
yourself in the mirror what do you see
and what do you say to yourself probably
the most egotistical things that I say
I'm probably most ego doubt when I'm
talking to myself which means that I've
got a lot of confidence in you go mmm I
rely really whenever I talk to myself in
the mirror it's always the same thing
which is like you're gonna do it man
you're good like like it's real good
stuff and it's not like false pumping up
I only do it seven times a year but like
something would have just happened
either adverse me or something great and
I'll look myself and say mm-hmm we got
this I got a funny Kevin Durant walked
off the field off the court the other
day against the Warriors and it was a
big game day before the Super Bowl and
they lost the first time I play in the
Warriors are having probably the
greatest seasons any best right yeah and
he did something that me and AJ took
note of he kind of shook his head and
said okay yeah and he gave me that like
okay do you one but we'll see you and we
got a shot I got this and it was that's
what I do with myself like there's
something good or bad is happening I
look myself in the mirror and be like
and I'll just say mm-hmm like I know I'm
built for this we like people who say
I've got something to offer the world
and it's very it's people are very
reassured by confidence you know all
scared that we're gonna come across as
arrogant but if you're on a fly and you
hit turbulence you want a confident
pilot if you're sick wouldn't you like
you're really covered a daughter got off
I'm the best doctor in New York I'm
gonna make you better I don't wanna goes
well I don't want to brag you know I'm
sort of okay sometimes but you know he's
better than me we don't want our kids
teacher to go well I'm not the best you
know I have good days we want to go I'm
the best teacher and I'm gonna give you
back your kid in a year's time rate
radiating confidence and talent you know
we pay for that and yet we're so scared
of saying I've got a gift I've got a
skill this is what I'm good
you see the two biggest enemies to
success number one self doubt number two
fear of the unknown we struggle with
self doubt we worry are we ready for
this
are we good enough do we actually have
what it takes to succeed confidence is
nothing more than believing in yourself
and believing in yourselves is nothing
more than doing the things that you once
didn't believe that you could do you see
confidence comes from competence it's
easy to believe in yourself when
everyone believes in you that's not what
I'm talking about I'm talking about
believing in yourself when you're not
ready believing yourself when no one
believes you believing yourself when
everyone tells you that you cannot do it
then you cannot make it that you don't
have what it takes that is when you need
to develop their unshakable
self-confidence that believe that you
can do it and confidence is not the same
as arrogance the arrogance is thinking
that you above everybody else confidence
is knowing that no one is above you do
you feel confident enough in your own
abilities that you can do what it takes
are you willing to bet on yourself not
just words but action how often you
invest in yourself are you willing to
put everything you have on the line for
your goals and for your dreams do you
bet on yourself or do you procrastinate
do you hesitate
are you perfectionist do you suffer from
paralysis analysis is the confidence
that we're good do you feel nervous
about bringing new music into this world
after not having done it for so long I
think it comes with the meat the music
you know it determines everything about
how you feel and I think when we made
this record the last few years we've
been making this record it was like we
were also on the same page about the
kind of album we wanted to make I mean
what is the point at this point put a
record out unless we think it's gonna be
like amazing and our favorite record
we've ever done and like our best work
and like you know we we had to really
fight to make this record it wasn't like
we just you know
glided into the studio and had a luxury
of time it was really like it was just
passion and the strive to want to really
make it and have to fight for it so with
all that hard work behind us and to
actually know what the record is because
we're addicted to it and listening to it
in their cars and like written just
about ready busting to share it there's
there is a confidence that comes with it
because and it's not it's more about
like knowing how much we love it and
knowing the people that are that are
actually supported us and that they're
waiting for and they're excited force
and those people that give us a
confidence the people that have given us
this life and supported us those as fans
I guess that kind of gets it can just
get you riled up it's exciting to share
it you know one thing that Skyy
mentioned in the last panel about
building relationships with people
before you need something from them so
really thinking about how do you reach
out to a VC you may not be raising
funding now you may be thinking about it
but starting to build those
relationships early so cam had that kind
of relationship he mentioned Mark's
sister which is he's one of the biggest
venture capitalists in Los Angeles tell
us a little bit about how you cultivated
that relationship and how it grew over
time um I think I had a level of
confidence that most people don't have
and what I mean by that is um I try to
make people relearn everything that they
think that they know about people like
me right traditionally a rapper is
assisting like oh he's just a rapper
it's a bad thing right but I started
getting frustrated with people throwing
that stuff at me and I would change it
and say you know what being a rapper
means having your finger on the pulse of
the millennial generation right to be
hot like jay-z for such a long period of
time you have to know what the young
generation thinks you have to know what
they dancing in a club what kind of
sounds they like what kind of shoes they
wearing what new car you have to be
ahead of the curve and you can use that
as an advantage so when they throw this
rapper thing at me I switch it around
and say nah that's what it is right and
then a lot of the people that are out
here get put in capital and all these
companies and invested in all these
companies they don't even use the
products like a lot of y'all could
probably tell me about snap more than
they could so once I started to realize
that it just became a confidence that I
started having and I would talk to them
like no actually it doesn't work
it works like this and then it'll be
like what and then I'll prove I'm wrong
and the next thing you know they're
listening to me for insight so it didn't
necessarily happen like that with
Marxist Tamar Souter was a person that
just recognized that and he was like you
know what I like your confidence I like
your understanding of social let's just
build a relationship and it started from
there so he offered to invest in me like
five six years ago and I would I just
wouldn't take his money I was like nah I
got my own money next thing you know I
started giving him my insight on all
kind of companies and I think he
understood the diverse opinion coming
into the room and how valuable that was
and that's why me and him built a bond
like that now I've got a special bonus
clip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the best life
30 questions of the day now it's not
enough to just watch a video you have to
do something take action so pull out
your worksheets and let's get to work
and if you don't have the worksheets for
this video check the link in the
description to get them for free
question number one if you were more
confident what changes would you make in
your life number two what promises did
you make to yourself that you need to
keep and number three what people and
resources do you need to be around more
to keep your confidence high and if
you're doing the best life 30 challenge
with me give me a hashtag best life 30
in the comments below so we could
celebrate with you self confidence comes
from doing difficult things when you
face adversity and you tell yourself
it's too difficult
you lose self-confidence when you face
adversity and you push through it you
act you go forward you build
self-confidence most people won't do
difficult things because your identity
is tied to the results you only feel
good about yourself when you win and so
you'll only do things where there's a
fairly high percent chance of you
actually winning and so that leads to
you playing small forever and always
doubting yourself you know you're
capable of more but you're afraid to
fail the trick to playing a bigger game
and building real self confidence is
feeling good about yourself when you try
not when you win celebrate the effort
not the results because you likely won't
get immediate results at the beginning
especially if you're doing difficult
things but if you tie your self-esteem
to your effort and you keep putting in
the effort you will get results to do
the difficult things you need
respect your effort more than winning my
biggest fear is around disappointing
people I hate the idea of letting
somebody down and so it used to prevent
me from taking action because I would be
so paralyzed by fear of letting that
person down that I would secretly hope
that they would cancel on me I remember
when I booked my trip to Brunei I was
invited to do a keynote speech in Brunei
to help their young entrepreneurs there
and I agreed to a month in advance and
then as we started getting closer to it
I started having mini panic attacks like
oh my god it's coming up oh my god it's
good why did I say yes
I hope they can't say I hope they can't
so I'll be checking my email three five
eight times a day expecting the sorry
Evan it's over it's not happening you
know we're not we'll still pay you or we
won't pay you doesn't matter but you
don't think how many more it's like yeah
you know I'm waiting for an email and it
never came so I had to go and that's not
just for the big things like okay that
makes sense it's in Brunei different
country never been there it's on
national TV it's a big deal you getting
paid a lot of money to go there great it
makes sense you're scared of that I'd be
afraid even on a small micro level I
remember being afraid of meeting
entrepreneurs and coffee shops and it
was one woman in particular that this
really sparked a change for me there's
one woman who I agreed to meet at a
coffee shop she was pure startup mode
and I remember just before the meeting
checking my email same thing I'd be
checking my email a couple times before
waiting for her to cancel and me waiting
for her to say I can't make it I'm
delayed it's not gonna work and and be a
bit yes no problem I can go off and do
something else it never came right she
never cancelled on me and so because I
was worried about letting her down I
stayed what half I would go to the
meeting I wouldn't cancel myself and I
would not show up because that's the
ultimate letting her down so I still had
to go and it ended up being such a great
conversation and I remember sitting in
the car afterwards and I'm about to come
home and I just had this fantastic
conversation with his beautiful person
and was able to help her was able to
shift her business was able to give her
a perspective that she wasn't thinking
about before was able to inject it with
believe that she was off now building a
better business for herself and I made
that happen in in a really short amount
of time and
was what made me feel the best helping
people get to where they need to go is
the thing that fills me up the most more
than making videos this is the thing
that fills me up the most and I almost
wish that it didn't happen right like ah
I wish that it didn't happen I was
waiting for her to cancel on me and I
remember having his moment sit in the
cars like what am i doing why am I so
afraid of this thing the thing that I
love doing the most is the thing that
makes me the most fearful and I almost
sabotage myself and so from that moment
I decided that I need to tie my my
self-worth my actions Mike my confidence
to the doing that it may not work out
that changes aren't gonna work out but I
may not work out and that's okay that I
need to show up that I need to push
through because the only way to actually
then gain your self confidence to gain
more respect for yourself is by doing
the difficult things whether it works
out or not if you want to join the best
life 30 challenge click the link right
here below me or if you want even more
videos on how to boost your confidence
check out the playlist right there next
to me continue to believe and I'll see
you soon
[Music]